had someone recently comment on my youtube channel
um they wanted to know why am i getting pcos i'm
not even 18 years old so i wanted to create this
quick video on pcos just to explain the simplicity
of it so you really understand it polycystic
ovarian syndrome poly means many and then we have
the word cyst okay many cysts but in reality it's
not true it's not really cyst it's follicles but
i'm not going to get into that but for right now
just understand that there's these little bumps
growing and there's many of them on the ovary okay
so we have polycystic ovarian and then syndrome
now a syndrome is not necessarily a disease it's
suggestive of a disease but it's a disorder having
more than one symptom that
suggests a disease okay so
all right what are the symptoms infrequent or
prolonged menstrual cycle excess male hormones
as in androgens infertility excessive hair
growth throughout your body thinning of the
hair on your head acne and insulin resistance
now if you look up this condition on wikipedia
it will give you a lot of general information
that that is not very helpful uh they'll talk
about the cause being genetic they'll talk
about the cause being potentially environmental
also they will tell you that pcos has no cure but
it can be treated with metformin anytime you're
trying to figure out some mysterious medical
condition um realize that there's usually one key
factor that you need to know to figure it out
there's one piece of information that explains
everything and that is rarely if ever found in
wikipedia or the first page or second page or
third page on google when you do searches and
so one thing that i'm really interested in is
doing videos on that key piece of information so
you can figure everything out with pcos the key
piece of information is this high androgens
can be caused by high levels of insulin okay
that's what you need to know in other words every
single one of these symptoms right here is coming
from high androgens because you have high levels
of insulin now what's interesting is that they
rarely ever check insulin levels they'll check
your blood sugar levels now you cannot determine
what's happening with insulin by checking your
blood sugars because you could have normal blood
sugars yet have high levels of insulin because
the insulin resistance will buffer some of that
blood sugar response until a certain point where
it can't buffer it and then it can't compensate
and you become a pre-diabetic and a diabetic but
for right now all you need to know is that your
high androgens are coming from the high levels
of insulin that's why they treated with metformin
because metformin treats insulin resistance which
will help regulate your insulin levels and help
normalize them okay but what's behind high levels
of insulin well if you're new to my channel i
every almost every single video i have is related
to that one topic you need to do healthy keto and
intermittent fasting is your primary eating plan
to help you regulate your insulin levels and then
get your pcos reevaluated because you are probably
going to find that you have a lot less problems
with this disorder why because you're getting to
the root cause if you're new to my channel and you
want to know what to do i put a link down right
below of exactly what you should be eating hey
before you go real quick i have a course entitled
how to bulletproof your immune system it's a free
course i want you to take it and here's why here's
you here is your environment everyone is focused
on this over here avoiding your environment but
what about here what about strengthening your
immune system that's what's missing this course
will show you how to bulletproof yourself and so
you can tolerate and resist your environment
much better by strengthening your own immune
system i put a link down in the description right
down below check it out and get signed up today